hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast genomics in public health and
microbiology I am Judy Oracle lab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots for more information please visit
lab routes comm you have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
a screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speaker professor ben
howden PhD dr. howdy is an infectious
diseases physician medical
microbiologist and head of the Houghton
laboratory located in the department of
microbiology and immunology at the peter
doherty Institute for infection and
immunity the laboratory is closely
affiliated with the microbiological
diagnostic unit Public Health Laboratory
MDU phl where he serves as director the
housing laboratory works in close
collaboration with this in your
laboratory and has close links with the
infectious diseases microbiology units
at austin hospital the scientists
research uses genomics molecular biology
epidemiology and clinical studies to
address a broad range of issues related
to invasive bacterial diseases in humans
especially those caused by a cephalo
cocci enterococci and other
antimicrobial resistance species working
closely with scientists in the MDU phl
dr. Hodgins group investing
the evolution epidemiology and spread of
bacterial pathogens of public health
significance such as my Syria gonorrhea
Mysterio monocytogenes shigella and
Salmonella species and Legionella
species I will now turn it over to dr.
howdy for his presentation okay thank
you very much Judy and thank you for the
opportunity to speak to you all the
topic I'm talking about is genomics in
public health microbiology the reason I
have an interesting Lisa's through our
research reviews genomics for many years
to understand how bacterial pathogens
are bold and spread and now as a
director of a public health laboratory
we're trying to apply this technology in
real-world public health microbiology if
you think about what the game changes of
being in public health or clinical
microbiology over the last a couple of
decades there's really two main lines
you know that of the development of that
the PCR reaction which was written in
the 1990s safe 1980s and 1990s and also
the use of our typing methods such as
pulsed-field gel electrophoresis and
more recently the development of more
details related diagnostics and those
these technologies have really changed
the way we do clinical microbiology and
also public health microbiology and
there's really no doubt that genomics is
another one of these game changes and
we're just at the start of this
evolution of genomics and how we're
going to use it to really change the way
we do public health microbiology and why
are we so interested in this technology
well it as I've said it a disruptive or
game-changing technology which can
really transform the way we perform
these these practices the year of
genomic medicine is already here with
the the technology being used in their
diagnosis and treatment of certain
genetic and cat disorders and cancers
but the application in public health and
clinical microbiology is lag behind a
little bit there's a really a major push
internationally to catch up here and use
this technology to enhance the practices
of these
mother balaji specialties so one of the
potential applications then of genomics
in this in these spaces well they're
very broad actually and that everything
you think of it you can find a way to
apply genomics to the question or river
the diagnostic essay or the type in sa
that you're trying to do but just as a
brief summary some of the key areas
where genomics will have an impact is in
the diagnosis of infectious diseases a
characterization of antibiotic
resistance mechanisms but also nap in
the way resistant bacteria spread
detecting and responding to outbreaks of
disease whether they be foodborne or
other types of microbial diseases
tracking the source of outbreaks this is
particularly the case for for example
for foodborne disease which I'll talk
about a little bit more already I've
better use genomics to really pinpoint
the source of contamination problems
that result in that outbreaks of human
disease and then there's another
application such as characterization of
unusual microbes so looking at microbial
species which are not typical pathogen
in humans and characterizing in more
detail and all and certainly also in
infection control and hospitals it has a
similar type of approach to using it for
foodborne disease characterization and
detection but using it in a hospital
environment to understand how pathogens
are spreading within hospitals and
trying to disrupt this spread and
genomics will help in all of these areas
so why are we so excited about genomics
in terms of the workflow in the
laboratory well here's just a slide that
summarizes the sample word for that
might be how we work in the public
health environment so we get a lot of
different types of specimens in the
laboratory whether they be from humans
food environmental animals and we have a
very broad range of diagnostic
techniques and also typing techniques
that we apply to these pathogens and it
means that we're doing a huge number of
different essays within the laboratory
and that was this would be a world on to
anyone who works in a clinical or public
health laboratory and this leads to some
reported other described that the
characteristics and the pathogen or
possibly the characteristics of a group
of pathogens are might determine whether
they're relatable Martin
there's been some some spread of our
particular pathogen one of the
limitations of this current workflow
will they work very well for us for many
years and then led to a lot of good
microbiological outcomes but they are
reasonably low resolution a number of
these and so we have a rough idea Bob
might be going on with the spread of
bacteria for example but we don't
necessarily have the detail some of them
are labor-intensive and some of them are
relatively expensive in terms of time
particularly start time and consumables
and so what are the potential advantages
of a genomics workflow then well it's
the higher resolution so this is the
highest resolution we can really get in
characterizing and microbial pathogen
counter the nucleotide level it's a
single a so so actually what we what we
intentionally can do is do a lot of our
public health microbiology using a
single type of essay and figuring in
different microbiological questions into
that and this might go right down on
strain type resistance violence and
mobile elements and it can also be very
high throughput so hundreds of samples
can be multiplex dinner in an essay and
you can get the answer reasonably
quickly it's not within hours but it's
within days and actually it's relatively
cheap when you're talking about a number
given essays you might be able to
replace with a single essay is it
backwards compatible we often get asked
questions from the people we report our
typing data to you know can you tell us
what the old typing results were as well
in some cases yes in other cases no and
I guess is going to have to be a
transition to this new type of our
typing terminology and reporting but
there is certainly the possibility of
some backwards compatibility which I'll
talk about a big run a moment so what do
I mean by a genomics workflow them well
this is just a summary of how it might
work within the laboratory also DNA is
extracted from bacterial species for
example it goes on to the sequencer and
then a large number of our sequencing
reads are generated and then the key
next step is the bioinformatics black
box which I've got in the middle of the
slide there and this is where all the
important analyses happens and where the
meaningful data was generated from all
of these are sequencing reads that we
get out of the genome sequencer and what
sort of information right
get out I've just got some examples
there on the right hand side of the
slide you could determine the resist I'm
oppler the species that is no does it
have a particular type of resistance
genes such as MEK a that you might find
in step 4 s mrs a does it have a
mutation in a particular gene such as
the sea mutation I've got there which
might lead to a certain type of
resistance such as quinolone resistance
in a number of different bacteria you
can also determine the relatedness of
strains I've talked a bit about this
already but you what I've got there is
an example of a phylogeny where you're
looking at the distance between
different microbial species and
understanding how closely related they
are to each other and then some other
things which are not necessarily
directly related to public health
service but also potentially interesting
are in a virulence gene characterization
and then also some more detailed
analyses to understand evolutions of
microbial populations to understand how
they're spreading and evolving over time
so just as an example from our own point
of view how do we set this up in a
public health laboratory it's not
straightforward actually and so it's
required a lot of investment in man in
hardware and this is robotic to the
automated DNA extraction and various own
rugby QC modules that are required
before you can place your sample on to
the genome sequencer and so these are
the sort of things that might be
required for laboratory that is
considering transitioning to a
sequencing based approach you can
outsource these tasks but it does
actually potentially increase the
turnaround time and if you're a
laboratory that needs to have answers in
a reasonably short turnaround time then
at this stage it's more likely that
you're going to have to have an in-house
approach and then the key thing here
which I've highlighted is the need for
bioinformatics support and this is
torsten who is our main bioinformatician
in our laboratory it isn't there's no
doubt that you can get the significant
benefits of genomics or without the high
level by automatic expertise that's
required to extract the meaningful
information from the data so that's a
key part of the setup so before I talk
about what we've been doing in a
laboratory I thought I discuss some of
the International progress because it's
been very significant actually
and you know there's been a lot of
progress made in the application of
genomics and public health and clinical
micro and these are just some examples
here so in the USA the FDA has
instituted a program of Salmonella and
Listeria genome sequencing and using an
online system called genome tracker
knocked up a bit more about that in a
moment in the United Kingdom public
health England is now transition to full
genome based typing of Salmonella
species so they get many thousands of
someone else refer to their laboratory
each year and it now stopped the
traditional typing methods and
everything every Salmonella species
undergoes genome sequencing and data of
rapid data analysis for reporting and so
they're playing a public health in over
the next few years is to transition to a
total sequencing based approach to
public health microbiology as also
advances being made in Canada and other
places this is just an example of what
is happening in the u.s. baby and I
think this is interesting to know
because there are two things mainly
because it's um the data is but be made
publicly available on a very rapid
timeframe and I've generated a model
where data can be shared across the
country very rapidly to to look for
potential one common links between human
and food ice lots of Salmonella and
Listeria to trying to find outbreaks and
pick them up earlier and so what's
happening across the u.s. is a number of
laboratories all have their in-house
sequencer whenever they get a new
isolated salmonella listeria that ISIL
is sequenced and then overnight that
data is uploaded to something called
genome tracker which is housed at NCBI
and so every morning is a new set of
data within in the system and the FDA
takes responsibility for reanalyzing all
of that data overnight and then
interpret in whether there's any new
interesting relationships between
isolates that should be investigated as
a possible indication of a new foodborne
disease outbreak
just to give a sense of the volume of
this sort of thing this is up until
December last year the number of assets
of Salmonella and Listeria literature
are now in the genome truck and network
and it's well over 10,000 Salmonella
assets now and roll over to a half
thousand Listeria iceless just shown the
volumes that are now being uploaded and
there's been this rapid increase over
the last 18 months so how does this help
I mean we do have traditional typing
methods but how is this Geno tracker
approach helped well these are slides
that are provided by the FDA just
showing how to some point out here that
this is the this area here is the the
epidemic curve that you would normally
see in a foodborne outbreak of disease
so that in the middle of this through
the epidemiological investigations they
would usually be recognition that there
was an outbreak of foodborne disease and
then the investigations would start to
try and determine the source of that and
using typing methods as well trying to
disrupt that outbreak but what's
happened here is this is a example case
where earlier in the India break before
it was clinically obvious the genome
tracker system was able to pick up very
close genetic relationships between
bacteria that have been uploaded from
laboratories across the united states
and alberta recognize that there was
probably a contaminated food source and
that's our led to an investigation that
intervened and likely led to the only
prevention of a large number of
foodborne disease outbreaks in this case
that shows the potential power of
genomics if you have data sharing in
real time to to really disrupt these
sort of things so there's some examples
of what's been happening internationally
just as an example of how we try to
approach this locally for any
laboratories that are considering a
similar to the path what we've done is
with vermin developed an applied
genomics enter that sits within the
public health laboratory but is also
within the research environment of the
university regular laboratory is located
and what that means is that we have
expertise both in public health
microbiology but all
also in the basic science I'd back to
your genomics so those two groups can
work together to to develop techniques
that are going to allow for really
applied genomics approaches to connect
in diseases and interestingly once you
start doing this then the the interest
in the technology and the application of
the technology starts to really become
very broad and so quite quickly we've
been asked to look at things like
outbreaks of disease such as an VRA or
vancomycin-resistant enterococci and
hospitals have been applying it to
Legionella when there's been potentially
operatively genera and also around
drug-resistant bacteria such as kpc
klebsiella pneumoniae which I'll talk a
bit more about in a moment it's also be
known a lot of work will commit food
pond disease and as i've mentioned
internationally this is where a lot of
the work has been done and so we
followed a similar path to try and see
whether we can get similar benefits from
the technology that you can we've been
seeing internationally and then there's
other applications such as looking at
tracking of antimicrobial resistance
species and also looking at other things
such as sexual transmitted diseases and
so reasonably quickly start to get a lot
of potential lab investigations and
request to look at things in it can
actually generate a lot of work very
quickly not careful about how you
strategically implement this okay so
some examples then of how the technology
is being applied and how it appears to
be helping me what we're doing from a
public health about a point of view so
the first is an investigation of
carbapenem-resistant klebsiella
pneumoniae that were very big
undertaking in Australia over the last
12 months many of you who work in the
clinical laboratory will know that
carbapenem-resistant Enterobacteriaceae
are are really a very urgent
international antimicrobial resistance
health threat and this is why because
essentially on the left there they're
resistant to almost all antibiotics this
particular outbreak am a number of the
most susceptible to gentamicin but
resistant to everything else and there's
a high harvested mortality and morbidity
associated with these bacteria if you
look internationally this is just a map
showing
in brand areas of the world that there's
been a largest number of cases of kpc
and klebsiella pneumoniae against if
there are number of regions where this
has happened but australia has had very
few cases to date what's happened over
the last couple of years of these are
the isolates that have been referred to
our laboratory for characterization of
cra-cra gene detection and you can see
that there's been increasing numbers of
carbapenem-resistant Enterobacteriaceae
and in particular larger numbers of KPC
to klebsiella pneumoniae and so there
was a particular type of bacteria also
with the same resistance element and
this made us wonder whether in fact
there were some local transmission going
on because previously most cases have
been internationally imported so how do
we look at the ISIS of trying to
terminus well I guess traditionally we
would have done something like look at
the antibiogram and this is the sum of
the isolate antibiogram and you can see
that's actually a little bit
heterogeneous and so that wasn't
particularly helpful all right let's
have the same resistance gene when it
was sequence of result and kpc to it was
really impossible to tell from looking
at from this point of view whether they
were related or not possible gel
electrophoresis could also be performed
and did suggest that their assets were
quite clonal but it's very hard to draw
and conclusive information from the pfge
results and so we undertook some genome
sequencing of the bacteria and this is
just a slide summarizing where the
bacterial fits all of the ones that
we've had recently quit within this part
of the tree here and so this is a
phylogenetic tree where the horizontal
distance describes the diversity of the
bacterial species and serve these
bacteria here which have a long branch
lengths are very different to the other
ones whereas the ones that can the
bottom here in red that have no
horizontal difference in there and then
they're very closely related and then
the other thing we did was because it's
june because we're using genomics were
able to compare our
due to the international publicly
available data sets over here on the
right in black are all the international
isolates on KPCC Pantilimon yay you can
see they fall into two different clades
when you compare them by genome
sequencing and then when you look at
where all the ones from our epic have
occurred they're all clustered together
and they appear separate from the ones
that have been found internationally all
these done uploaded to the international
databases so if you zoom in then on this
part of the tree where the weather very
clean-looking strains occur so this part
of the tree here then what you see is
that you start to see and some
differences in that the bacteria in this
part of the tree and it looks like
there's four different groups that four
different clades on KPCC to klebsiella
pneumoniae circulating and mother and
here there being a color-coded by the
referring laboratory we could see that
there's a number of different
laboratories with quite closely related
strains and down the bottom here you
have a scale which is the number of
mutations but represented by this branch
lengths so that's 20 snitch so 20 single
nucleotide polymorphisms and they can
settle rudder the bacterial species have
much less than 26 between them
suggesting they're very closely related
and using genomics you can also get
other interesting information like
defining the type of resistance Jim its
present in the bacterial species and in
this case it was a particular type of
role characterized resistance plasmid I
won't talk to me more about that but the
other thing you can do with genomics is
also understand the pendulum so rather
than just looking at the genome that
shared between all the species you can
look at the total gene content and
that's what this green image represents
here and so all of the bacteria and
where where there's green they have the
same gene present and you can see
there's very little variability between
the bacteria in this tree suggesting
that they are very clonal all very
closely related so how do we determine
whether there's transmission occurring
across the whole tree or whether it's
part of the tree well what we can do is
look at the pairwise snipped
that's how many mutations are between
the different populations within that
tree and you can see here that there's a
bimodal distribution and so there's some
left up here with less than 48 snips and
most likely would represent some groups
of clonal dissemination and so then if
you apply that back onto the tree what
it means is that there's actually four
groups that you've been color-coded here
that represent the four possible
transmission networks I'm just
highlighting nuclear and so this just
helps us try and understand the
transmission dynamics and so the top
group here they are all closely related
but they all come from different
laboratories and it's not clear whether
there's been transmission we need more
epidemiological data and that's a key
messages that the epidemiology is still
really important these next two groups
here they're the two groups are closely
related and they appear to come from the
same laboratory so their improbable
transmission and learn about laboratory
is and then further down you have asked
that are almost genetically identical
but they've come from different
referring laboratories and so could this
be community transmission or common
source exposure or in a hospital
transfer and so the epidemiology is
required to overlay onto this to really
understand what's happening and so we've
now done the epidemiological
investigation of really unconfirmed that
the genomics has clearly described the
the population of these bacteria and
very clearly given you can find close
relationships between the patients that
have similar isolates even though they
came from different before in
laboratories and so it's been extremely
useful tool to investigate this outbreak
and so the summer is that that the
genomics shows the majority of a recent
and bacteria in Melbourne a similar look
closely related they have a particular
type of resistance gene and appears to
be for transmission networks and this is
allowed the Public Health Program where
actually the government to go and then
investigate this further and influence
and interventions to prevent further
transmission so that's an example of a
drug-resistant bacteria so now I'm just
going to move on and talk about our
foodborne disease that of listeria
monocytogenes it's ubiquitous
gram-positive organism human infections
occur through food boron transmission
and usually that there's 60 or 70 95
cases each year in Australia and there's
been a national surveillance initiative
since 2010 so in the laboratories of
public health laboratories in australian
international there's a range of
different typing tools that are useful
experience some of the vultures up to
four to five or six different typing
methods of using this is just summarizes
some of those type of methods are might
be mostly like a sequence type in pcr
binary typing multi-roters MLB a and
then PF g is the most definitive typing
method and so when you think about that
number different methods and quite a lot
a lot of our negative to perform lows
and so what we've done here is we've
applied genomics to our population to
investigate whether using a genomic
approach will improve resolution but
also decrease workload for a
stereotyping or laboratory and so here
we have a another tree so it addenda
granted scrubbing a relationship between
some Listeria isolates you can see from
the scale here that there's a very small
number of snips on our tree so it's only
25 so that all of these are slits here
are essentially identical and this is a
group of isolates where the PF g which
is the highest resolution tightly method
here is identical and you can see that
all all the other is hunting methods on
the right essentially the same
particularly phe the mlst and the MLB a
so previously these assets would have
been considered the same but when you
look at the end when you go back and
look at the then the tree here you can
see that it's actually designated for
different groups and so what this is
allowed us to do is have a higher
resolution analysis of the genetic
relationship between bacteria and so
that it's actually separated these into
different groups and when they go and
check the epidemiology on this it does
actually validate the fact that these
are different sources of contamination
and so the type in use of mysterious in
our whole genome sequencing really can
replace number traditional methods his
superior discrimination is actually
cheaper and more cost effective than
using the traditional methods we've also
been able to develop tools where we can
infer the mlst the zero type and the
binary type from the genome sequence and
so this allows us to report both on that
the genome sequence the relationships
but also to a club the traditional
typing methods however it's not possible
using short read sequencing to predict
the MLB on or the pfg types accurately
so how do we report them well this is a
challenging part of transitioning to
genomics because we are reported to
epidemiologist who need to use this data
to investigate potential common source
outbreaks and they used to have in
binary type data ie that is a particular
names or numbers given to certain type
in typing results so they might have
abused to a particular pfge group or a
particular cero time for example if
you're a reporting and analysis based on
sniff distances between bacteria it can
be quite challenging them from them to
transition to this and so this is at the
moment the method we're using where
we're doing a Apollo genetic
relationship I'm looking at the snip
distances between bacteria and then
highlight and using a traffic light
right interpretation ie raleys highly
likely to be related Green is not likely
to be related and yellows and between to
really highlight the risk stratification
of what cases should be investigated
compared to others and then the
epidemiologist cannot apply that
information to performing the
epidemiological investigations so that's
all I was going to say about Listeria
but are similar to listeria you could
apply this sort of approach also to
other bacterial species and other
foodborne diseases such as salmonella I
guess the problem with Salmonella isn't
the the volume is much higher so we're
only getting tens or possibly hundreds
of last year each year but we get many
thousands of Salmonella each year so to
make a a transition from traditional
methods to pure genomics for salmonella
is a lot of
and because the efficient genomics
workflows to make that possible so I'm
just going to talk a little bit more now
about something that's a bit more in the
research environment that does
significantly translate into
understanding how the control
drug-resistant bacteria in hospitals and
that's some work on the genomics of
vancomycin-resistant enterococci and so
the re are a common cause of
colonization and infection in hospitals
globally and certainly have very
prominent issue within Australia and we
don't really understand why VRE remains
such a problem learning so mesenchymal
outbreaks of the area thought to occur
by transmission between patients and
therefore the effective our infection
control interventions really should
limit cross transmission that despite
implementation of such strategies the
incidence of vrv infections continues to
rise in Australia and we're particularly
concerned because we we have a very
effective national hand hygiene program
within Australia and that's been very
effective actually at reducing the
number of mrs a infections so here on
this image you can see the number of
them mosa infections at our particular
hospital but we were investigating this
and back in 2001 it was very high
whereas the rate of VRE or BSC infection
was quite low and after the introduction
of an effective hand hygiene program is
in a month dropping them mosa infections
and then over that time VRE affections
have actually increased such that in the
late 2000s for the first time we had
with high numbers of VRE bacteremia at
our hospital than we did it with the mrs
a and similar stories are being told
around Australia so it's not clear why
that why that's occurring one of the
interesting things about VRE in
Australia is that we have a different
type of resistance element it's a van be
element which is a bit different to what
is common in the USA and in many parts
of Europe
and that the van be element is
interesting because many people actually
carry this cell resistance element in
their normal flora the Dow particularly
within them and a relative in the bow
that's also been demonstrated with with
with in mice at least that you can take
a an anti road with it carries its Bambi
element and mix it with a banker mice
and susceptible enterococcus in the bow
and it will generate a bre and so this
made us think a bit more about what is
actually going on with the re in
australian how common is this
transmission of this resistance element
between the anaerobes in the human gut
and BSC isolates to generate new clones
of the REM this is hardly driving this
issue of failure of infection control to
to stop the early and so this study here
that put up the phylogeny from user is
looking at cases of BSC and the re
bacteremia doubt hospital right over a
10 to 12 year period and looking at the
genetic relationship of the Iceland's
and so on the left here we have the
phylogeny of the isolates and so this is
as I said over 10 to 12 years and all
the ones in black are the ones from our
hospital and the ones in yellow ones
from other hospitals throughout
Australia and even and ask that from
overseas the first thing you can see is
there's a lot of diversity in this
population so that even at our one
single Hospital in Melbourne we had
assets that um represented those that
were seen in other hospitals in Darwin
and western Perth in Western Australia
and also an isolated in the middle here
two came from the USA and so you can see
there's a lot of diversity in the
population that we're seeing at our
Hospital and reflects the diversity that
we see nationally and possibly even
internationally and then the other thing
that we also note is that this is real
change in the type of clone that we're
seeing so over the years the earning
type 17 the re was seen throughout the
whole time period but in the later time
periods we have emergence of this new
clone called EST 203 which appeared to
be a social association's rapid increase
in that they are
infections will send at our hospital so
what we did is we use the genome
sequences to understand the resistance
element and so this light here
summarizes the characteristics of the
transposon that carries the Bambi
resistance element and we were looking
at the weather the sequence of the
transpose almost different we also
looked at the site that we transpose on
inserted into the genome of cagliari the
direction it was inserted and also what
the coupling sequence was around it and
this tree here is one that's just based
on the transposon sequence not on the
whole back to your Gina but just on the
sequence of the transposon I think some
one of the most interesting things here
is that the eye slits in red here from
anaerobe so these aren't from human vrs
but they're from communion anaerobes you
can see that at least one of the
anaerobic sequences of the transpose
almost totally identical to a large
number of them and transpose on
sequences from humility rei slots
suggesting but or indicating at least
these are essentially identical so what
we did then was we overlaid these
characteristics of the transposon onto
this core genome foraging of our show
during the couple of slides ago so what
we have here is all of the BSC and VRE
isolates and the ones that have habits a
resistance transposon have these colors
here among the don't hear other bses so
what you can see is that this
intermingling of the BR ES and the
vehicies so here we have a BSC and right
next to what we have a bre that's picked
up a transposon here we have a number of
vse strains and here we have a day
already that some picked up a transposon
and what we then did is we went through
and looked carefully the transposon
characteristics and defined which of
these strains or which of these isolates
were newly re clients are then emerged
independently and each of these grey
arrows here indicates a new bre clone
and you can see from this that actually
a lot of these and they re on this tree
were actually new clients so that it
does not suggest horizontal transmission
rather generation of new clones of the
early however this one here is an
example of where all of the all of the
backbone called genome was the same and
the transposon was the same and they all
came from the same time period
suggestion this was clonal dissemination
was a lot of the others were independent
its own generation on video and if you
look if you tally this up what what we
had here was we had 36 VRE isolates in
this population and appeared 18 of them
are independently generated and even for
this new clones and this new st 203
which is the 100 moves in the last 12
years nine of them appeared
independently generated so this is very
important for understanding emergence
and dissemination or by bre and the
conclusions and insights from this of it
the bank mice are susceptible a fake
email very important part of this
problem so it's not just about VRE and
transmission of the re but it's the
backbone it's the vsc that really
underpinned the problem of they are
really no hospitals at least in
Australia and it's pretty clear from
this that the gut anaerobes our
potential sources on from the resistance
element particular this transposon 1549
outlet about half of the bre rightly or
writers by de novo evolution rather than
transmission between patients in our
hospital so what they need the
implications of these sort of genomic
studies for controlling antibiotic
resistant bacteria well a patient being
treated with antibiotics could become a
source of VRE even if they're not
exposed to another patient in theory so
VRE screening and ice and isolation will
not recognize about the half of the
patients that have this type of vse an
identification and isolation of patients
been stranded vse not just fear itself
might be required to control the area
obviously that's a huge undertaking them
may be totally unrealistic it's probably
going to be a combination of anybody
control policies enhanced cleaning and
universal precautions may be more
effective for the only
however there is also clear is also
clear demonstration and clonal
transmission or dissemination on that
previous slide and so it's a combination
of the two it's not just about in vivo
generation but it's also not just about
most criminal transmission and so this
is really led to a rethinking of how be
re-emerges and spreads in Australian
hospitals and rock mark be the best
approach to try and control it in future
okay so I've talked mainly now to this
point about how genomics will help us in
public health microbiology that is
included borne disease characterizing I
slits that are referred for from
molecular typing and working at
infection control interventions but
there's also a port or a discussion at
least about the role of genomics in a
clinical microbiology lab and if you
think about this some and I think in
future this will most likely be the case
but then there's probably a lot further
we work to be done before it would be
immediately transferable if you think
about how a clinical microbiology lab
works and there's quite rapid them
processes will go through the pathogen
isolation to identification to
susceptibility testing and reporting and
clinical decision making that if you
look in the literature about the role of
genomic unit in a clinical lab you start
to see a lot of papers emerging now
where they describe different
methodologies that might be relevant to
the clinical rate and that might be for
example the direct detection of
organisms from clinical samples in
southern some papers now emerging on
this identification about viral
pathogens in clinical samples by
real-time sequencing and even quite a
prominent case in the New England
Journal of Medicine looking at terminal
diagnosis of neural occurs ferocious by
next-gen sequencing on a on a clinical
sample or obviously that the genomics
workflow is not it doesn't easily fit
within a clinical mark I like at the
moment but there's also papers coming
out describing methods for improving
turnaround times and ways to approach
how we might apply genomics in a
clinical lab such as sequence
directly from single colonies and other
papers that describe how this marketing
be achievable and then the other thing
that we can do with genomics is we can
rapidly look at antibiotic resistance
elements which I've already alluded to
and so there could be a role in future
for predicting or characterizing
resistant isolates although at the
moment the phenotype is much quicker to
perform than it is to perform a genome
one area where there may not be the
cases in them TB for example and we have
quite a bit of work being done on using
genomics to rapidly predict the resistor
of mycobacterium tuberculosis either
from both cultures or possibly even
directly from clinical samples map is
something that's probably most likely to
come into practice earlier than the
other using other areas of antimicrobial
resistance so if you look then at what
time did the criteria that we use in the
clinical laboratory to decide whether
our test is useful or not it really
genomics doesn't fit the bill just yet a
number of them for example for in terms
of the speed of testing and the genome
sequencing really can't compete with the
traditional methods except possibly for
tuberculosis intelligence activity it
doesn't really add much at the moment
and all that doesn't help it organism
identification susceptibility testing in
terms of specificity yes it's the most
the highest resolution sort of
characterization we can get is a better
than current alternatives not at the
moment or that might be complementary to
some of them are tickly for tuberculosis
or other unusual pathogens and is it
likely in future to alter impatient
management in some cases yes four things
were it's difficult to get answers with
traditional methods and then in future
there might be more useful very specific
genetic characterization of microbial
species to help inform treatment
approaches such as an unpredicted noble
mutation or finding novel mutations that
might be associated with subtle
resistance mechanisms for example so the
current challenges in implementing
next-gen sequencing and diagnostic labs
are there to know the scale and capacity
so most
amex projects now looking at hundreds of
thousands of genomes whereas in a
routine diagnostic laboratory there
might be hundreds of thousands per year
so this is not achievable in the short
term there's going to be some
difficulties in workflow integration in
particular turnaround times the intended
usability and expertise in the clinical
environment they don't have a lot of
that at this stage and in one thing
we've found is there's even issues about
data storage and security and so its
genome sequencing generators a cup of a
couple of Giga bases of data and so once
he's starting to do hundreds of
thousands run into problems with data
storage and also data security and
trying to share data between
laboratories and clearly the turnaround
tons of a final reports irrelevant and
the limited expertise and cost so just
to summarize their know this is some
summary slide for the talk really
genomics technologies and bioinformatics
tools will transform public health
microbiology there's no doubt about that
however then many existing methods in
the diagnostic micro lab unlikely to be
immediately superseded by whole genome
sequencing as partly due to a lack of
knowledge and training amongst that the
clinical micro workforce which is
something we have to address and the
areas and most utility of diagnostic
laboratories are likely to be resistance
gene detection and epidemiological type
and so so much of a public health royal
really and in the short term the exit
place is roughly too concentrated in
reference laboratories and tertiary and
centers and really in future the applets
must be compatible with a comment of the
work in the bar area for genomics has
been introduced into the clinical
microbiology of our tree so just from a
personal perspective within Australia at
least what's the view to the future well
that within Public Health microbiology
would hope that all labs transition to a
genomics workflow which is hard to put
fast and cheap and most importantly
similar to that the FDA model of a
common online system to upload samples
with some automated standard analyses
and simple reports of visualization this
could really enhance the practice of
Public Health microbiology in Australia
and enhance our ability to detect them
respond to our
exit from microbial disease so that's my
final slide and I'm finished and I'm
ready for any questions and answers that
are you may have thank you for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session i would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window Lancers
many questions as we can I'll give you a
moment to formulate questions
if there are no questions today I would
once again like to thank dr. housing for
his presentation do you have any final
comments dr. happen thank you all thank
you for the opportunity to speak I I
guess I would just like to say you know
it's a challenging area and I think
there's a lot of uncertainty about how
we're going to move forward in this area
over the next few years but there's no
doubt that the technology is advancing
rapidly and and that we're going to
really see a rapid increase in the use
of this technology in the public health
and also in a clinical environment in
future years and so thank you very much
for the opportunity to speak and I'll
sign up wanna thank you thank you again
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through may 12 2016
you'll receive an email from lab roots
alerting me when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event see you next time bye